foreign
[Music]
you liked most of Kenobi and Boba Fett
exists I know you're a nice long soak in
the back to tank when this is done now
Disney's got a new Star Wars streaming
show that fans never asked for in this
prequel of a prequel about the third
lead in Rogue one and it's the best
thing they've ever made this show does
not look around
and or
experience a Galaxy that looks different
from the one we're used to because it
wasn't shot in The Giant Egg where
Disney makes everything else in the
first Star Wars streaming show free from
cheap nostalgia
[Music]
merchandising bait Jedi Sith lightsaber
Skywalkers the forest Tatooine or comedy
[Music]
honestly it's hard to believe it's in
the same universe as all the other crap
those of you who
said when we enter this building we are
in a
emergency powers to the Supreme
Chancellor
Diego Luna is back as Cassian Andor a
human board on planet orphan but who
grew up on ferricks a working-class town
with a strong commitment to the
percussive Arts
[Music]
when Cassian kills two cops outside of a
brothel
oh no no embark on his epic journey to
be anywhere other than where he is at
any moment I just need enough to get out
of here I can't be here we need to go
tomorrow we're getting out of here we're
leaving I need to relocate for a while
you gotta get out of here I'm done come
on Cass get your whole life ahead of you
sit down for once and enjoy a beautiful
sunrise with a loved one oh right join
the fight to take down the Empire with
the rebellion's goth space Uncle I made
my mind a sunless face stellen Skarsgard
shines in his dual role as a leader
willing to sacrifice anything and anyone
and a sassy antique dealer who lets his
hands to the talking gift for your
husband I have some new things coming in
soon
[Music]
funding his operation is mon mothma a
galactic Senator with a relatable
problem she spent way too much money on
Star Wars how much is missing four
hundred thousand deeper in your
understanding of this original trilogy
briefings Giver as a key figure who
bankrolled the rebels at the sacrifice
of her family but like no big loss there
that's just so heartful go deep like
super deep into the inner workings of
the Empire with Cyril corn a mall cop
who accidentally kicks off the Rebellion
while his boss is away at a conference I
was a good Deputy inspector he's a
domineering little dweeb with mommy
issues been in my private box I have a
voice of knowing tricks are for kids mom
cringe as his Oedipus complex locks on
to Dedra Miro a high-ranking
intelligence officer with a mean case of
mean face
but that's not how you pictured
Jennifer's voice huh in a show with such
a deep Fascination and the banality of
evil and the complex inner workings of
bureaucracies you'll swear it was mainly
intended for adults have you saw New
Hope in theaters you're 50 it's time
Thriller to show that puts characters
first but still propelled By
multi-episode plot arcs like a heist
that sets Cassian up as more young
Stalin than young solo cassian's
Hometown being slowly ground down under
the Empire's boot until the little dick
Droid that could tips the scales
oh no it's odd
and a three episode Prison Break
sequence starring Andy Circus that is so
[ __ ] good he needs to hang up the
mocap suit immediately this man has
earned the right to use his own human
face forever just the best
so forget all your expectations about
Star Wars and Disney plus and prepare to
learn what the Rebellion against the
empire actually demanded of its
Believers their freedom their souls
their very lives and 7.99 a month until
Disney actually makes season two you
better leave the show alone Disney
there's only one force corporate
crossover will accept one
I've always wanted to touch him I like
the texture of Yaba is something I need
to discover then I'm obsessed with the
texture of java I'm very curious to
actually touch that texture I've been
dreaming
his skin is just something that obsesses
me touching his you know like his belly
like I'm not in love with Java that was
one big mistake I made but I have like
seven yavas at home
starring San Diego
Barron starkin
the moon don't trust the ISB in division
23.
drop that zero and get captured by Miro
beehive rise up going forward to build a
breakthrough Empire 2.0 and succeed in
an increasingly competitive world we
will need to be extremely hardcore
Caesar the means of production
from the Nook of Saul and cousin
Empire Records
everything you need here is on the wall
water night light and fun
you can get as much as you want top
table wins flavor wait water and food
tubes right next to my bed and sometimes
the food tube has flavor that's down
right luxurious by my standards
oh this is genius
I talk to myself but no one ever listens
oh my God the quarterback is toast all
the information is on the task blood for
the blood God skulls for the skull
Throne you just got luigi'd